[Musique]
aujourd'hui on se parle du premier
ordinateur qui se plie il s'agit du
lenovo thinkpad x1 folk
[Applaudissements]
on se lance dans cette boîte on a le
premier ordinateur pliable ça c'est
vraiment une grosse nouveauté et j'ai
vraiment mais vraiment hâte de venir
découvrir ça
[Musique]
ah ouais c'est très très très bizarre
c'est hyper bizarre alors en fait là
protect elle se décale là je me retrouve
avec un espèce de deux jours et salle à
assas line ok j'ai compris
donc ça en fait je pouvoir l'utiliser
comme un cheval et pourra poser sur une
table dans un sens ou dans l'autre
vous êtes plutôt malin mais surtout
c'est la sensation à l'ouverture voyez
c'est assez marrant cet écran qui vient
ce plié alors je sais j'ai l'habitude
des smartphones qui se plie mais c'est
vrai que d'ordinateurs qui se plie gg
pas trop l'habitude et ça me fait
extrêmement bizarre
j'aime beaucoup l'idée en tout cas au
niveau connectique g de l'usbc je sais
pas si c'est une aération haut parleurs
je vais le tester d'ici quelques jours
donc on en reparlera j'ai alors de
l'usbc la de l'usbc là ça doit dépendre
de la façon dont laquelle il est il est
pliée ici ça doit être un os 9 volumes
là j'ai quatre trous se doivent pour le
moment être des micros à vérifier et un
côté qui est très compact ça fait penser
à un très gros bouquet en fait en termes
de format en termes de prise en main le
côté curé sympa parce que très premium
ici je sais pas ce que j'ai deux sous
windows bien évidemment si je savais pas
que c'est un ordinateur eh bien écoutez
je saurai pas ce que c'est c'est très
très très particulier comme format en
tout cas j'aime bien alors faites voir
si je viens l'allumer assure que j'ai
une caméra là juste en haut là ok les
neuf parce que si je l'aimé comme ça hop
donc si je l'avais comme ça ils
s'ajustent et si je le pli qu'est-ce qui
se passe ah ok je vais récupérer un
clavier donc là le clavier je le ferme
fut retrouvé mon bureau un peu le
standard soit chaud en plein écran
soit je peux venir switcher comme ça mes
paramètres sur le bas et mon bureau sur
le haut soit me retrouver avec mes
paramètres sur le haut ça sur le bas est
ce que je peux le déplacer je peux le
déplacer ça pour du multi tâche c'est
assez intéressant et en fait ça va
vraiment venir apporter plein d'usagé
donc on sera le test plus tard là c'est
vraiment une découverte mais voyez
lorsque je viens le plier comme ça j'ai
le choix entre mes différents modes le
clavier qui se situe en bas donc là je
peux complètement avoir mon clavier sur
le banc et avoir toute une zone pour
venir écrire sur le dessus donc si je
veux ta pays si taper un paramètre stop
l'écran ok c'est cool
ce qu'on pourrait se dire est ce qui s
intéressent en regardant comme ça c'est
le déport de la caméra sur le côté si
par exemple j'ai envie de faire de la
conf call avec des collègues
est-ce que l'emplacement de la caméra
sur le côté et ce qui est le mieux est
ce qu'il aurait fallu l'imaginaire au ca
je vous en reparle parce que pour
l'instant je ne sais absolument pas si
je le positionnent comme ça
eh bien ça me met comme un espèce de
petits cadres cadres photos voici rigolo
si je le positionnent comme ça ça me le
cal à la verticale pour venir travailler
aussi de cette manière là je peux venir
le plier un petit peu moi j'aime
beaucoup il ya ordinateur là c'est
vraiment intéressant
qu'est-ce qu'on a encore à l'intérieur
fait voir on a ainsi naît on va
retrouver deux boutons 1 ici est en
dessous ensuite qu'est ce qu'on retrouve
là dessous et well comme un clavier
comment ça va s'adapter l'histoire est
ce que c'est un clavier qui veut venir
se superposer ah ouais ça c'est malin
regardez ces aimante et donc je le mets
pas au top comme ça je le positionne il
ya un changement
génial hélas j'utilise comme un
ordinateur un petit peu standard très
très très bonne idée
alors attendez ça marche comme ça mais
est ce que ça marche comme ça aussi
parce que chez les nouveaux des fois non
là ça marche pas à ce si je le montre
non là ça marche pas moi je vois qu'avec
clément là ça déconne ça ne veut pas il
ya vraiment un sens et un seul alors par
contre là vous pouvez pas le plier le
faire mais avec un je pense je préfère
de bêtises mais à 6 vous pouvez regarder
vous le prenez vous le plier il va se
positionner avec ça c'est très drôle
et lorsque je leur ferme comme ça voilà
voilà en fait ça vient justifier le jour
c'est à dire que lorsqu'il est fermé un
peu classique mme ensemble clavier et
bien j'ai le petit jour qui vient se
faire ici
et lorsque je viens insérer le clavier
l'intérieur c'est ici et là il ya plus
de jours du tout ça s'est très très mal
en plus de ça j'ai retrouvé un petit
place pour mettre un nom stylet pour
l'emmener partout avec moi
donc là on est vraiment dans l'idée de
on the go je le prends je pars ça c'est
vachement bien vous avez une vraie
solution avec un ordinateur qui se plie
que vous emmenez facilement alors par
contre lorsqu'il est comme ça vous en
douterez ça vous fait vraiment un petit
écran je connais pas la taille tout de
suite je vais potassé le produit je vous
en parle dans quelques jours vraiment
pouvoir les usages mais l'idée comme ça
je la trouve vraiment super c'est
extrêmement modulaire très très très
très bonne idée
ok et trop chouette qu'est-ce qu'on a
encore ici bah écoutez je crois que on a
fait à peu près le tout des infos sur le
produit thinkpad x1 fold a priori ça
c'est un bouton bluetooth et le charger
le charger le chargeur qu'est ce qu'on à
bloc de charge 65 watts assez assez
standard j'aime beaucoup et innovation
avec ce produit on se parlera des usages
dans quelques jours parce que vous en
douterez a produit atypique usage un peu
différent ça reste l'ordinateur
on va donc l'utiliser comme un
ordinateur mais il ya plein de façons de
l'utiliser
laissez-moi quelques jours le temps de
m'imprégner de bien l'utiliser de bien
comprendre tout ce qu'on peut faire avec
et je vous en reparle d'ici quelques
jours
c'est un ordinateur qui coûte au prix de
base 2008 109 euros c'est pas un produit
qui est destiné à tout le monde
la technologie et nouvelle l'innovation
et l'a donc forcément il est un peu cher
j'imagine que dans les années à venir
les prix auront cependant un petit peu a
diminué et pour 2008 109 euros
vous avez en intel core i5 l16 g7 pour
être très précis 8 gigas de ram c'est de
la lpddr2 4x un disque dur ssd de 256
giga en pcie élevé m e vous avez un
écran de 13,3 pouces 1136 par 2048
pixels
hall est bien évidemment avec une
luminosité jusqu'à 310 carte graphique
intégrée du wifi 6 et une batterie de 50
watts heure et sur la config la plus
élevée vous serez à 3479 euros en
produits très atypique avec une très
belle innovation signée lenovo on en
reparle d'ici quelques jours laissez moi
le temps de bien appréhender de bien
découvrir de bien maîtriser pour vous
donner tout mon retour sur ce produit
moi j'aime beaucoup et l'innovation ne
trouve très cool effectivement on est
sur un produit qui est cher qui est même
très cher mais l'innovation et là on en
reparle dans quelques jours vous avez
donc elle vient me rejoindre à vous
abonner surtout à dire ce que vous en
pensez vous en bas en commentaire qu'est
ce que vous pensez de cette machine
qu'est ce que vous pensez l'innovation
ce qu'elle peut vous tenter oui non
comment marc m'a tout ça on va en
commentaire et on se retrouve d'ici
quelques jours on est gros bisous
beaucoup d'amour
[Musique]
ce plan